[Music]
welcome to the 31st Gartner lecture I'm
Wesley Harris head of the Department of
aeronautics and Astronautics and I have
the distinct honor of not only welcome
you to 31st Gardner lecture but to share
some background as to the naming of this
distinguished lectureship it is named
after Lester Gardner mr. Gardner was
born in New York City in 1876 and those
of you who are history buffs realized
that's a same year in which US General
George Armstrong Custer was killed in
the Battle Little Bighorn but that
didn't stop Lester he found his way to
MIT and earned his Bachelor of Science
degree here at MIT in 1898 he left MIT
and proceeded to study law at Columbia
University and then he really made his
switch to technology and became quite
active in radio broadcasting including
arranging the first demonstration of
ship-to-shore radio telephone operations
with David Sarnoff on the receiving end
as you know David went on to lead RCA
Lester then made some serious contacts
with the leadership of aviation in the
u.s. having recently met Glenn Martin in
our own professor Jerome C Hunsaker the
three of them organized the Gartner
publishing company shortly after the war
the first great war began and Lester
proceed to the
rank of major including organizing 89
Aero squadrons that were sent overseas
and he organized these squadrons at
Kelly field and Texas
following the war he became a major
figure in aviation in this country
serving as a delegate to several
international conferences Rome in 27
back in Washington DC and 28 Berlin and
29 and again Rome in 1938 he then
organized the Institute of aeronautical
sciences in 1932 and later with the
American rocket Society IAS became the
AI double-a mr. Gordon was instrumental
in creating the huntsacker professorship
at MIT he became a honorary fellow of
the Royal Aeronautical Society of London
he was a fellow of the Institute of the
aeronautical sciences in the US and he
received the Guggenheim medal in 1947
for outstanding achievement in advancing
Aeronautics now for the main course it
is my distinct honor and pleasure to
introduce dr. Harrison Jack Schmitt who
will talk to us today on trip to the
moon in the legacy of Apollo Jack is a
geologists a pilot an astronaut an
administrator a business person a writer
and a former US senator he assured me
that he also loves to play squash born
in Santa Rita New Mexico he never found
his way to MIT but he did to Caltech
where he earned his Bachelor of Science
degree finally finding the East Coast
somewhere in Cambridge
PhD down the road a little bit
Jack is a fellow or honorary fellow in
at least nine technical societies
including the American Institute of
Aeronautics and Astronautics and the
American Astronomical Society he has
more than 30 special awards including
honorary degrees I've picked only a few
of them for example Jack received the
Republic of Senegal
National order of the lion in 1973 he is
the first Sherman Fairchild
distinguished scholar at Cal Tech in
1973 and he received the GK Gilbert
award bestowed upon him but a planetary
geology division of the Geological
Society of America in 1989
he was selected as a science astronaut
by NASA in 65 he was a lunar module
pilot in Apollo 17 which left earth and
jewel in December 6 1972 in return on
December 19 under his control it landed
in the valley of the taurus littrow Jack
is the only scientists and the last of
12 humans to step on the moon he
continued his distinguished career of
service having been selected as US
senator from the state of New Mexico of
1977 to 82 he is a member of our family
and that he serves on the cooperation of
the Draper laboratory he is also a
member of the cooperation of audible
sciences Jack
well thank you Wes and I guess I did not
realize that someone's standing here 31
years ago was just preceding flight to
the moon which occurred about a little
over 30 years ago
and what I'm going to do today to start
things off and have a little fun is show
you about 10 minute video of most of a
trip to the moon it's obviously quite
compressed but I think you'll enjoy it
and then we'll talk a little bit about
what all of this may mean in various
ways to the past as well as to the
future the this video is we put together
for our 30th anniversary celebration at
the Smithsonian Institution last
December and if I unfortunately they
didn't equip me with a checklist so
we'll see what happens there we go
this you'll have to suffer through my
narration and maybe a little sound in
the background
those were the patches of the various
Apollo missions that did indeed go to
the moon are all emissions and at least
all of them but particularly the later
ones had a great deal of science
training we put in three four or five
days a month of exploration training
often using the operating version of a
lunar rover but also all the equipment
that we would have so they use of that
equipment became second nature as
possible and we could better employ what
some people thought was a reason for
sending people the moon and that is
their minds getting suited up on the
before launch we were scheduled to
launch at about 10 o'clock on the 6th we
actually had a two hour and 40 minute
delay leaving Earth on December 7th here
you see Ron saying goodbye through his
helmet to his wife Jan
Jeane trying to hurry us along as usual
I'm bringing up the rear Charlie Buckley
closing the door on us but I had second
thoughts I guess and he wouldn't let me
out maybe I just needed to visit a
restroom somewhere I don't know the
launch of Saturn 5 is truly spectacular
at 16 and 6.8 million pounds seven and a
half million pounds of thrust at this
point and very very slow acceleration
initially getting to four G's at two
minutes and 45 seconds and then staging
and a steady one-and-a-half G's the rest
of the way we had great outstanding
views of the planet Earth throughout our
whole flight to the moon this particular
sequence we may remind you of Apollo 13
the movie where we were docking ron was
knockin with the lunar module so it
would go along with us into to the moon
wouldn't make much sense to go without
it I wouldn't think the although Apollo
8 would disagree with me they had a
great time without it landing this pitch
over occurred at 8,000 feet and if you
look very carefully we've got I'm sorry
about the light I hope you have a better
view of this than I do but you see the
shadow of the lunar module up there that
is in the zero phase Point Sun directly
behind us and if you now you're seeing
the shadow get closer to the surface and
we had touchdown streaming away I hope
you can see the streamers there that's
the dust great deal of dust in these
lunar in the lunar debris about 60% I'm
gene asked me to come in about 60% is
less than 100 microns gene had asked me
to come over and help him get a drill
core out of the surface
he learned to regret such a request here
as you will see
this was our first excursion we're still
getting used to once again I am still
getting used to one-sixth gravity this
is the second discouraging and you and
and the only time in the whole mission
that I did an individual sampling we
usually worked as a team as you'll see
later and I have already dropped the bag
full of sample so I'm getting that up
and leaning back you can see I have done
this before I'm quite dirty and I just
forgot how to hang on to that sack now
I'm getting a little bit upset and about
this point I was informed that the
Houston Ballet Society was interested in
my services and so I I figured a better
demonstration was appropriate and you'll
see that here in just a moment I finally
got my sack headed for my tool here now
this is an actual demonstration of
ballet style on the moon now you of
course follow my face again now a much
better way to operate on the moon and
you see here at the location where we
found the famous orange soil or orange
fire classic glass that was a trench I
had dug right in there working as a team
gene always got the sample bag a little
bit too high for me but still that much
more efficient than what you just saw a
few moments ago the this glass is we
will talk about a little bit later has
become a very very important part of the
Apollo legacy in that it it is calling
into question some of the consensus
opinions about the origin of the moon
and some other aspects of lunar
evolution this was not totally not
totally unexpected discovery here you
see that deposit it's in the rim of a
crater called shorty this is an omen for
photographic control over here and
that's a pretty good color
representation actually a little bit red
it should be a gretter here in the
yellower here but that's about the best
we've been able to do so far down in
Mission Control a variety of people
including Jim Lovell right there we're
watching over our shoulder we never gave
him a chance to tell us to do much but
nevertheless they felt good about we
knew gene had a certain technique as did
most of the pilot astronauts I don't it
must be a genetic - ha they'd like to
hop across the surface they call this
their bunnyhop as you can see even it is
not too successful sometimes and in a
few moments you'll see how really it is
to work across the lunar surface the
best way to do it but that'll be a
moment or two now this cameras on me
taking a pan if you look carefully
there's my face it's one of the few
faces if they don't laugh the only face
to be photographed on the moon because I
kept my visor up being a good geologist
I wanted to make sure I saw the rocks as
clearly as possible and so the
gold-plated visor spent part of its time
up now this is a little skiing
demonstration little parallel skiing
not too good as you can see catch an
edge everyone as well now more more
appropriately for moving across the moon
is a is using a cross-country skiing
technique and here you see that
technique applied gliding above the
surface running through a boulder field
this was on a third excursion and you
can see we had a great deal of
confidence by this time to go running
like this and really that ultimately I
think will be the mode of transportation
of choice you can over a reasonably
level surface you can probably get up to
ten or fifteen kilometers an hour that
way without expenditure of much effort
the parts are from the moon not a really
good photograph gene tried to persuade
me to go outside and get one
about a half a G acceleration and we're
off the camera head mounted in my window
looking down now at the surface
there's the decent stage our launch
platform our tracks going back and forth
to an antenna I laid out here and to the
outside Ron Evans now taking these
pictures as we approach rendezvous we
had a very rapid rendezvous is what was
called direct ascent ron abboud ron mout
going outside for his spacewalk actually
space swim is a more appropriate term
because you really do pull yourself
along and don't use your legs at all of
course hi mom isn't is is required and
this was about an hour long spacewalk
that he had that to gather canisters a
film that had been exposed during his
three days of orbiting operations
independent of our activities on the
surface I was here in the hatch helping
to keep trying to keep him from getting
tangled up in that umbilical which you
can see has a life of its own he would
hand me the canister I'd stick it down
and hope the gene could keep it from
flying out into space so we were
reasonably successful with that three
days after we left the moon we entered
the atmosphere at 35,000 miles an hour
pulled about seven GS to make sure we
were captured and then flew our way down
to where the carrier was waiting for us
maybe actually parked there carrier's
about five miles away from our planned
impact point afraid that we might land
on their carrier I thought that was not
very nice the but splashdown of the
final Apollo mission and certainly the
most recent flight to the moon you see
here as photographs taken from a
helicopter that almost immediately
deployed maybe seals who then put a
floatation collar around the spacecraft
as a safety precaution and here I think
this may be Gene Cernan
the last to leave the ship actually I
think gene left first that was sort of a
non Navy tradition now I hope you caught
quickly gene and I both graphs the
railings of the of the steps there
because you really do have some trouble
balancing Ron wanting all over the red
carpet there is the Apollo Heritage is
really quite remarkable I think history
will be very kind to to it for what not
only was done but what was learned the
maybe one of the most important parts of
what we left at least at our site was a
map of where all the Paulo landing sites
are that was something I insisted that
we have on that plaque and then also the
legacy of having this view here in a
moment of our planet Earth from 34,000
miles away on our way out to the moon
really a remarkable photograph still the
most requested photograph from the NASA
archives and with that I'll see if I can
turn this off did that work now I see if
we I may have destroyed the whole
process here of getting the PowerPoint
presentation up there we go
the legacy of Apollo comes in many this
is a little more serious part of the
discussion hopefully not not too serious
it comes in many aspects certainly it
was born of the Cold War the and the
political goals of both Eisenhower and
Kennedy were met by it in its ultimate
form I include Eisenhower here not
because he provided the main impetus to
apollo kennedy certainly did that
but if eisenhower hadn't insisted
personally on the development of the
saturn v launch vehicle and associated
engines it wouldn't have happened and so
he does deserve maybe a little more
credit for this and then he has gotten
normally in the in the history books
there really is a dichotomy in what
Eisenhower apparently felt about put
said publicly about putting men into
space and certainly to the moon and what
he did to ensure that we had
a heavy-lift launch vehicle which had no
other purpose but to put men yeah and
the vicinity of the moon so I'll let you
figure out exactly what was on his mind
in doing that and the leadership of the
Soviet Union I think was clearly
intimidated enough so that Reagan's
Strategic Defense Initiative later
became credible literally America could
succeed where the Soviets apparently
could not in such an endeavour us pride
and confidence was enhanced in a time
when as you recall a missile gap and and
other things were creating a bit of
unease in the United States among its
people and as I travel the world through
many years later I found that there was
a a promise at least to other peoples of
the world that their future could be
better than it than their past I'm not
sure we've fully lived up to that
promise as yet but still it is there now
the cultural legacy is is somewhat
interesting as well the power created a
new evolutionary status for humankind in
the universe there was a rapid
improvement in the human condition on
earth due the acceleration of
technological expansion again it
probably would have happened but
certainly much more slowly than it did
future terrestrial energy and
environmental improvement is now
possible both with the increase in
conversion efficiencies of of ordinary
energy sources and with the new
potential of lunar helium-3 fusion that
we'll talk about a little bit more in a
few moments and indeed on the moon at
least we've identified clearly space
settlement resources hydrogen oxygen and
water and then ultimately I think food
as well for space settlements there are
not resources that would have a value
here on earth but certainly would have
value to future inhabitants of space the
keys to the success of Apollo comes in
many different forms and you have to
think of these as the kinds of things
that have to be in place if we are going
to do these kinds of things in deep
space our take on major significant
projects anywhere a sufficient base of
technology
she certainly came from the World War to
the Cold War and the decisions that
Eisenhower made during his administer
second administration there was a
reservoir of young engineers and skilled
workers that the 1957 launch of Sputnik
generated the pervasive environment of
national unease some of you are old
enough to remember that that did exist
particularly in the campaign of 1960
there was a catalytic event of course
that brings the focus to the effort that
was presage by the the Sputnik launch
but the the one event that really began
to focus the attention of the Kennedy
White House was Greg Aaron's flight in
April of 1961 and we had at that at that
time an articulate and trusted in
persuasive president who actually had
been thinking about this and was
preparing himself for this well before
Gagarin's flight that is at least weeks
before in some of the decisions he made
on the budget cycle in discussions with
Jim Webb the and and we after Apollo the
Apollo 204 fire at least we put together
a competent and disciplined management
management was moving along quite well
up to that point but still not at the
point and level necessary for operations
in deep space again I would submit to
you that when you ought work in deep
space at least for the foreseeable
future most if not all of these
conditions are going to be required now
because of its currency let me just
digress slightly here relative to NASA's
worst accidents and there are I think
some common threads the Pala tool for
fire the Challenger and Columbia
accidents really began with the
acceptance of abnormal as normal we also
at the time had a lack of a technically
experienced administrator whether that's
significant or not I'll let you decide
but all three have that common thread
the lack of a top-level managerial and
operational oversight take
place was not happening under Webb it
was and it was not happening in the case
of the other two and a lack of a
mechanism for appeal in the chain of
command of management I'll tell you one
thing about Apollo there was always a
way to get a good idea moved up that
stopped pretty much at the end of Apollo
good ideas did not move easily through
the system I had many experiences my own
I saw many others were engineers
astronauts scientists at any level if
they had a good idea and could in that
idea would stand the test of discussions
with their colleagues that would move up
and through the chain of management very
very important to have that in these
kinds of very complex opera programs and
projects now only with Apollo 13 do I
think you can see a pure set of
accidents and design flaws that can be
blamed where we just did not anticipate
in the design and in the operation a
number of things that could go wrong all
at once and that really is the
background of the Apollo 13 accident and
one of the reasons why it was it was
fixed reasonably quickly and we got back
to flight quite quite quickly as well
now let's talk more in more detail about
the scientific legacy a first-order
understanding of the origin evolution of
the Moon clearly has as resulted from
Apollo and and of course the the later
unmanned programs such as Clementine and
lunar prospector with a nice assist from
Galileo as well may it rest in peace we
had developed a basis for the
interpretation of those of that post
Apollo information about the moon by the
analysis of the lunar samples from
Apollo and it that in turn became the
foundation for comparative planetology
comparative planetology really didn't
wasn't much there were a few people like
Piper and shoemaker around who
considered themselves I think Planet
ologists but the as a discipline it was
just was not active very quickly with
Apollo and even before Apollo but in
anticipation of it comparative
planetology became an important
discipline there is recorded on the moon
a record of the history of the inner
solar system and it is a guide to the
early history of the earth and Mars and
that is particularly a record of the
impact Commentary asteroid impact
history of the inner solar system we
also have delineated a lunar resource
potential not only for use here on earth
but also clearly a potential for use in
space and not just on the moon but
elsewhere and that's not too shabby a
legacy scientifically in spite of what
some of my scientific colleagues might
try to paint now the major just to give
you an idea of what we have learned
about lunar evolution and this just
remember this chart really could not
have been created without Apollo we
certainly have learned a great about the
beginning the age of the Moon is roughly
that of the age of the solar system not
exactly and it's in that not exactly
that things really are starting to get
exciting there is a debate and then most
of the debates I have now here in red
whether Earth impact or capture has
resulted in the origin of the Earth's
moon the consensus 95% or more of the
people in my community of planet
ologists would say earth impact that is
the impact of a mars-sized asteroid
resulted in the origin of the moon I'm
not one of those that agree with that I
think there's some major problems when
we'll talk about that in a moment one
new concept that came out of Apollo uh
very very soon after the Apollo 11
samples were analyzed both John wood at
the Smithsonian Observatory here and
also others immediately realized that
the moon had differentiated that is
there had been a magma ocean that had
crystallized in sequence and had
resulted in a chemical differentiation
of the elements in the crust of the Moon
are in the upper mantle of the moon down
to at least 500 kilometers that magma
ocean was a new concept that is now
being considered as a viable concept on
all of the terrestrial planets for this
period of time
there was a residue from that magma
ocean that has become unfortunately now
it's called your creep creep is
potassium rare earth elements in
phosphorus rich material your means the
original creep because we'll all we see
at the surface of the Moon is creep
that's not original it's just the
signature of it I'm sure that excites
you very much then there comes this
important crater in history that we now
have and and in that may be one of the
most important aspects is the definition
now on the moon of continental scale
basins that I'm talking about basins
that are two hundred two thousand
kilometers in diameter or more and these
are basins that formed on the moon and
almost certainly formed on earth as a
result of the impact of extraordinary
energetic objects from space there were
there are many other basins and large
basins there's something like 45 or 50
of these large basins which are greater
than 300 kilometers in diameter some the
oldest of these have apparently resulted
in the crust of the Moon being
strengthened as this as the liquid that
we called the residual liquid from the
magma ocean the the so-called creep
moved up to the basin and solidified
because the last 14 or so of these large
basins have mass concentrations in them
which have been supported now for almost
four billion years so the crust has to
be extraordinarily strong for that to
have occurred coincidentally a it also
appears that during that period of Young
Basin formation the core of the Moon was
active and we actually have evidence now
andrás it of remanent magnetism on the
far side of the Moon at the Antipodes of
these young large basins that presumably
indicate that a circulating core dynamo
was present during this very brief
period of time maybe no longer than 100
million years now there is this is
another area of great controversy within
our community is whether or not that
period that I indicated there may be
four or five hundred million years of
cratering didn't happen all at once and
that is one of the
primary rationales for the proposals to
go to this to the far side of the moon
to the center near the center of the
South Pole akin basin that is a basin
2500 kilometers in diameter to see if we
can't resolve some of these questions
about whether you had about a hundred
million years of intense impact activity
on the moon about 3.9 billion years ago
or whether it's extended over four or
five hundred million years
either way the these large basins do
represent a new source of debris in the
solar system entering the inner solar
system that we really hadn't been
contemplated before we generally have
thought of some kind of continuum of
impact activity and in the near inner
solar system dying off gradually with
time here it appears that particularly
if it is a single cataclysm of a hundred
million years duration something
happened in the outer solar system to
begin to send objects into the inner
solar system a much more frequently
large objects much more frequently than
it happened before one of the very
intriguing possibility now during this
cratering period there appears to have
been significant deep igneous activity
and the moon probably the result of
pressure release due to these large
impacts on material that was almost at
the melting point anyway and that and
those so-called mgmg sweet magma has
moved up into the crust I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on that the next
major episode was a formation of
basaltic Marya those dark parts of the
Moon that formed the image of the man in
the moon or the rabbit in the moon or
whatever character you happen to see on
any particular evening and depending on
what you were doing early in that period
the so called crypto Marya have been
identified these are covered by the
ejecta from the young large basin so
that's why they're called crypto we only
see hints of them because of other amol
impact craters that have exposed them
the main Marya episode was between about
3.8 and 3 billion years ago then it
began to die off gradually with time
until the the using crater counts
estimates of age do using crater counts
greater frequency size frequency counts
we think that there may have been
igneous activity in one part of the moon
as as little as 1 billion years ago but
realize that almost everything that I'm
talking about here on the moon is
happened a long time ago and it gives us
a window into the early history of the
earth now I'm not going to go into this
other than to show you this diagram to
indicate that if you just look at the
first 50 60 70 billion years a million
years million years of the history of
the solar system we are learning a great
deal about what was going on and not a
small part of that as a result of what
we have learned of the Moon in
particular the Apollo legacy extends to
the issue of planet esmolol
a grinning the inner solar system on
through the development of these magma
oceans proto cores of the terrestrial
planets and then also the issue of down
at the bottom here of when did the cores
of the various terrestrial planet
actually aggregate we know a lot about
when core forming materials separated in
the terrestrial planets but that I
submit is a separate issue of when you
actually formed a core and we actually
using the the reason we can we can get
into all of these kinds of issues now is
because of the identification a few
decades ago of what are called extinct
isotopes these are isotopes that have
very very short I half-life's
decay to a definitive daughter product
that you can now measure you don't see
the isotopes anymore but you see the
daughter product aluminum-26
is one of the more important ones about
a nine million year half-life excuse me
about a seven seven hundred twenty-eight
thousand year half-life
hafnium 182 is another one that has the
nine million year half-life this is one
of those identification of those
isotopes and the ability of mass
spectrometry to measure extremely small
amounts of materials literally atoms is
giving us this kind of an opportunity
now to understand the formation of a
solar system around a sun-like star
really really exciting time for people
who are in this field now let's go back
to this business about giant impact it's
a very attractive hypothesis in that it
explains one thing very well and that is
the high angular momentum of the
earth-moon system however it can't
explain in my estimation the geology and
composition of the lower mantle of the
moon the challenges that it has is that
we are seeing increasingly particularly
in the analysis of the orange glass that
I showed you in the video and a green
glass that was belatedly identified in
the Apollo of 15 sample suite in those
we are seen evidence that the lower
mantle the moon that is the that is the
part of the moon below about 500
kilometers has never melted in its
entirety never differentiated that is
crystallized separate crystals minerals
and it has chondritic signatures in it
particularly for tungsten for lead and
in a very high volatile content relative
to anything that we see at the surface
of the Moon the seismic evidence and
trace element data and suggests that you
have increased alumina as a result of
the lack of differentiation
garnett present before below 500
kilometers I see Jim Thompson in the
audience you'll know that I'm always
interested in finding garnet somewhere
having done my thesis and related kinds
of rocks and so there this these kinds
of issues are ones which so far the
proponents of the giant impact theory
have not have not been able to to deal
with they are trying and by increasingly
complex models but I think that when the
final result is in when we finally know
more than we know
right now that will find that the
capture of an independent co-orbiting
small planet seriously needs
reconsideration that does have some
problems at least based on the little
bit of modeling that's been done to date
what is really needed in this question
is for some very very bright graduate
student hopefully one in this audience
who will undertake to begin to model
capture now in a much more systematic
way than it's ever been done and and at
least become competitive with a level of
computer modeling that's done for the
capture hypothesis now I do think though
that this issue of the very large basins
is one of very great importance to a
terrestrial geologist right now and
we'll get in why in just a moment these
are some of the basins that are that are
are some are non-controversial the South
Pole Aiken basin which you don't see
well in this picture but is right in
this area is is attested to by by all
workers in the field the Procol Harum
basin Don Wilhelm's and I and a few
others think is an enlarger basin that
has been seriously modified by other
impacts there's a hint of this prospect
what I call the prospector basin in some
of the data from prospector the same for
Clementine Basin here and maybe a
cryptic far side small topographic
anomaly there the statistical analysis
of the frequency of these large basins
for a body the size of the moon
suggested to Don Wilhelm's that we
should have seen about 14 of these
we I've only shown you the possibility
of five here and and those kind of
analyses are always subject to some
debate but nevertheless however many
there are they almost certainly occurred
on earth as well and and here you see a
topographic representation of those
basins and a South Pole Aiken becomes
much more obvious as a immense
topographic low the lowest point here is
12 kilometers below the mean lunar
radius it really is one heck of a hole
for the moon even poke alarum shows a
general topographic low there as well
now the these large basins may well
relate some of you in the audience
we'll know that people in our field talk
about the creep hop spot that's a
concentration of this potassium rare
earth element phosphorus material in in
the on the front side of the moon that
may well have been caused by the
migration of the residual liquid to a
low-pressure area we've already talked
about a little bit about the mimsy sweet
soo pressure release melting and and and
also there's an issue of a knellman ight
that's an iron titanium oxide rich
cumulate that may have overturned under
the Procol Harum event to give you these
young mario i mentioned that are about a
billion years old that are also titanium
rich those are fairly detailed issues
that we don't need to go into today
unless there's some additional interest
in it the more importantly are these
little continental scale basins my
estimation is that they were forming on
the moon and all the terrestrial planets
between about four point two and 4.5
billion years ago one of the more
interesting aspects of that is that just
recently in the last two or three years
we have workers have been able to
identify 4.4 billion year old
terrestrial zircons zircons are very
stable hard minerals that seem to last
forever under proper circumstances and
in some of the oldest settlements on
earth we are finding to tribal zircons
that is sedimentary zircons the cores of
which show ages of this kind in the 4.4
4.3 billion year old that's again shows
you what mass spectrometry is able to do
these days on a single crystal of zircon
give you an age of this nature but the
thing is where do they come from and
certainly it's in the same time frame as
at least my estimates and I think
Wilhelm's estimates for the ages of
these large basins zircon is a product
of late-stage magma differentiation here
on earth we it's a very familiar mineral
to us water would increase that the
amount of impression Olymp act melt
volume from one of these large impacts
and a differentiation of that impact
melt may well have resulted in these
zircons and
in fact they're the oxygen isotopes of
the zircons are consistent with water in
the magma from which they form so I
think we're beginning to bring that
those two stories together slowly and
it's a very exciting story indeed
because it begins to create
extraordinary diversity in the Earth's
crust right almost from the very
beginning of Earth history and of course
begins to even relate in some indirect
ways to the questions of the origin of
life now the old large basins in general
the ones greater than 300 kilometers in
diameter we've talked about them a
little bit the Apollo 11 site is in one
of them that's Mari tranquilo taught us
down here the ceramic Tata station which
is a young large basin Apollo 17 landed
right there it's here this is another
this is Facundo taught us another old
large basin not nearly as distinct as
these younger ones that that these all
have masks on send them these do not
they do have a ma refill but not as
thick in the old large basins as as you
would expect now the issues here we I'm
not going to to spend your time on these
these are again issues that will be of
interest to some in the audience but I'm
sure not all I had to do with the
strengthening of the crust as a result
of these young the old or old basins we
talked about the Cataclysm and I'm not
going to dwell on that further but we
might talk about why I think the
Cataclysm is an artifact it's an
artifact of these late young impacts you
had some 14 of these which distributed
ejecta throughout almost all the Moon
caused a great deal of resurfacing and I
have a feeling that that's what most of
the evidence of this so-called Cataclysm
is telling us we will have to wait and
see there are other some other ages at
Apollo 16 Paolo 17 cites that suggests
that older impacts did indeed occur the
I mentioned the global effects of the
young large basins on this age
for the Cataclysm there is a jet to
covering the crypto Mario which is
global no question the ejecta from those
lighter impacts was global and there are
a few of those samples as I mentioned
now I do want to though emphasize the
importance in the studies of the history
of the solar system to begin to think
about what the source of these impactors
were whether it was 100 million years or
400 million years I see the PC now is is
reacting to my Mac generated PowerPoint
by spelling out every sentence there's
certainly some new accretionary
reservoir appeared masoor s-- is to
consider would be the Oort cloud which
but through an interaction of a passer
steady stellar body or cloud being the
long potential source of long period
comets of course nobody has ever seen an
object in the Oort cloud but it has
pretty well established itself as a
article of faith that it's out there
more maybe more important to look at is
the prototype for belt interaction with
the large of the large commentary
objects we have out there some 800 now
I've been identified there are more than
a hundred kilometers in diameter I think
so we know they're out there but as the
gas giants evolved in their orbits they
would influence the the orbits of those
commentary objects and may well have
caused them to be injected into this
inner solar system main belt asteroids
Jupiter interaction with the
planetesimals that formed in the
asteroid belt and the expulsion of the
fragments from that belt may well be
another source or some combination of at
least two and three and maybe even all
of these the now the implications of
intense cratering on the earth and mars
i think are quite important to consider
that's it this is what the far side
cratered Highlands look like we have the
southern uplands of the moon so much the
same character this just happens to be a
picture of the far side highlands it
they're saturated with crater 60 to 70
kilometers in diameter saturate
mathematically saturated with craters of
that size so you can imagine the level
of violence that was taking place
it created a mega regolith some 25
kilometers thick it's well mixed on the
scale of hundreds of kilometers and with
a significant implantation of solar wind
hydrogen in the in in that material
I suspect that be in a hydrous
environment planet with a hydrous
environment such as the earth and mars
that clay minerals with a dominant
mineral species at this time because
that's what happens to minerals that you
grind up vitrify and put in a water
environment they turn to clay and I
think it's important that we think more
about just what it means to have that
kind of a mineral as your dominant
mineral species at the surface of the
earth and indeed of Mars the
implications of all of this may have a
great deal to do with life certainly a
general impact in by intense impact bar
environment from 4.5 to 4.2 billion
years we had clays and possibly sulfides
in various environments there were
dominant in hydrous environments up to
3.8 billion years 3.8 billion years is
the end of the major cratering period in
the inner solar system global soup for
organic synthesis as a result of this
the clearly there must have been organic
molecular synthesis on earth prior to
3.8 billion years mineral catalysts I
believe were very probably involved in
this synthesis and but large basin
formation up to 3.8 billion years
prevented any systematic development of
replicating life forms it wasn't until a
large Basin ceases to form that we start
to see evidence of replicating life
forms on earth and that is just almost
exactly within those limits right at
about 3.8 billion years fossils at 3.5
but evidence isotopic evidence of life
processes taking a underway
at about 3.8 billion years so I don't
believe that is coincidence the end of
the large basin formation suddenly
allowed replicating life-forms to
actually take hold they may have taken
hold before but but may also have been
wiped out the geochemical heterogeneity
in the earth crust we've already
mentioned the zircons I think show that
now at 4.4 billion years an important
part of this whole picture clearly
global hostility to life prior to 3.8
billion years but a continuous
compatibility for life after 3.8 billion
years yes there were certain points
where the species of the earth took a
beating and it certain points in
geologic time after that but I doubt if
it would have been possible for anything
happening in the solar system to have
wiped out life on Earth after 3.8
billion years now let's talk a little
bit finally about this access to our
lunar resources it's it's not a pure
science issue but it does relate to one
of those more serious problems affecting
the world today and that is we're going
to have something like 10 billion
Earthlings by 2050 excuse me let you
think about the implications of that
number it may even be larger that
implies and this is my estimate
something like a factor of eight
potential increase in energy demand how
do I get to that number well a factor to
to stay even with the 2000 demand and
depict your own number I pick about a
factor of 4 or more to meet the
aspirations and of developing countries
and to slow population growth now you
might want to add an X Factor here to
mitigate climate change which ever way
climate goes warmer or cooler
technologically the way you mitigated is
with energy mitigate its consequences so
there is some very large factor it's
resulted in an increase in energy supply
now I think you all seen this picture
it's useful in various ways it certainly
shows where energy is being used and
where it's not being used it's essential
certainly for the health economy and
safety of the United States and I would
submit for the preservation of our
freedom if we are not able to
continually increase our use of energy I
think we're going to be vulnerable to
many in many different ways but we are
also vulnerable if we continue to use it
in the way we've been using it in the
past now let's talk about some fusion
fuel cycles as they're relevant to the
moon and what we found on the surface of
the Moon the first generation fuels your
most of you will be familiar with it's
been the focus of billions of dollars of
federal and international effort to
develop a deuterium tritium fuel cycle
using tokamak technology primarily where
your primary a reaction product is a
neutron that is then captured in the
walls of a reactor and converted to heat
and then converted to electricity heat
converted to electricity
another first-generation cycle that
isn't very popular because of its very
high Neutron flux is deuterium deuterium
it does have some other applications too
for developing Neutron sources and the
like but it still has to be considered
one of the first generation fuels second
generation fuels are not being looked at
by anyone systematically other than the
group we have at Wisconsin that I'm
aware of although we don't know what the
Chinese are doing and right now the
Japanese are more interested in the
deuterium deuterium cycle the term
helium-3 is it has a great advantage
because theoretically what you get out
of it is a proton which is obviously
positively charged and controllable and
does not create the problems neutrons
caused in the creation of radioactive
and damaged first walls a third
generation fuel theoretically again is
helium-3 helium-3 that has not been
demonstrated to my knowledge as a
in terms of effusion cycle but we expect
that we will probably have such a
demonstration with the next few months
at Wisconsin using a new machine and
that is even obviously more advantageous
because of the increased number of
protons produced which again can be
converted directly or electricity now
the in Wisconsin we have this laboratory
Cluj device which of course no one at
MIT would ever be caught dead with a
device that looks like this built at the
products left over from other research
experiments we have just been working to
have a much nicer looking device you see
here thanks to the initial design work
done for the Marshall Space Flight
Center they no longer are apparently
working in this field but they're a
company that built a device for them
built this for us with some
modifications and this will be used for
our helium 3 helium 3 research without
putting any deuterium in it at all this
gives you a maybe a feeling for what it
looks like to look into one of these IEC
devices and inertial electrostatic
devices where you have an outer grid and
integrated with a potential across them
across which you accelerate your your
reaction products we've gotten to a very
high rate of reaction steady state now
this is not pulse this is steady state
and goes on for minutes and in fact it
can go on for an hour at a time or more
at this point the this is about a
million OTT mistaken power that you see
in that last picture the availability of
helium-3 is well documented we've seen
it in all the samples that have been
brought back from the moon we know a lot
about its distribution because it is
co-located with high concentrations of
titanium due to the its retention and
the mineral ilmenite again iron titanium
oxide current estimates are that if you
take the moon as a whole which you
wouldn't do you have it down to three
meters about a million
metric tons of helium-3 embedded in the
lunar soil over the last three or four
billion years and the geology of those
soils is really well understood it if
you were an economic geologist looking
at this I think I can convince you that
we we know an awful lot about the lunar
regolith based on the landings we've had
and based on remote sensing that's been
done since the significance is that one
ton of helium-3 can produce ten thousand
megawatt years of electrical energy
that's a lot that's about what a city of
ten million people will use today in a
year the so some 40 tons looking again
this for two thousand of helium-3 would
have provided for our entire US
electrical consumption in that time now
you would never expect to have to take
charge of that market instantaneously
you would enter it slowly as new plant
and comes required and old plan was
retired if you could compete with
existing sources of energy now one
another way to look at the value of this
helium-3 is that again if a plant
existed today to use it the value of
today's oil prices would be of a ton of
metric ton of helium-3 would be about
four million dollars four billion
dollars so maybe with that in mind it's
about time we took another walk on the
moon and with that I'd be happy to take
any questions at time permits
a couple of decades what do you think
that they will probably be looking for
there and is based on your experience I
strongly suspect that their primary
motivation is national prestige and
competitive with the United States in
some way but the fact that they seem to
be talking about the moon and some of
the ways they have I wouldn't be a bit
surprised that if if the truth were
known they probably have a lunar
resource initiative in mind as well
certainly the Japanese have been active
in this field since the potential was
helium-3 was first identified by the
University of Wisconsin folks at the
under dr. Cole sense key but and I
suspect the Chinese have pretty well
been monitoring that as well we don't
know we meet with the Japanese regularly
every two years to on the fusion
technology side of things and so we know
we have some insight into what they are
thinking and doing it's an important
part of their thinking relative to their
lunar program and which they've had in
mind for some time
we just don't know whether this is
something the Chinese are thinking of
it's not going to surprise me if they
are very familiar with what's been going
on in the open literature on this
subject all right I can't tell you
whether the United States Congress would
react react the way it did to this the
launch of Sputnik and then to support
the president President Kennedy after
the launch of Yuri Gagarin I just don't
know I don't know it's awfully hard to
predict as I talked to some of you
earlier how the political system is
going to work at any given time are not
work as the case may be and that is the
reason I have looked much more because
it's more predictable I think and I can
target what I have to do at at getting
the private sector involved to get back
to the moon it it's just if you do your
job right in business planning and an
implementation then you can keep
investors interested in what you're
doing and have a sustained commitment by
investors to a to interim as well as
long-term returns on investment I find
that a little easier to tackle than
trying to figure out what the
government's going to do next and so
that's where we've been putting most of
our effort is trying to put together the
business plans for the early businesses
not the lunar we have some general
strategies for the lunar power
initiative but mainly we've been looking
at how you use these electrostatic
fusion devices at low power levels for
useful purposes here on earth the first
one we're looking at is to is not very
far away in terms of technology and that
is to have a 1 watt device that can
produce positron emitting isotopes at
the point of use for PE T for positron
emitting tomography and where you can't
do that today today the isotopes used in
PE T Diagnostics are produced by large
cyclotrons in large urban areas the one
of choice today fluorine-18 has 110
minute half-life which you can transport
at a few hundred miles but it starts to
become more difficult you have to have a
large excess to transport it much
farther than that there are other
positron emitting isotopes that we can
handle that have about a 10-minute
half-life nitrogen 13 for example and
that is very attractive because unlike
fluorine-18 it can be used in
diagnostics for pregnant women and
children whereas fluorine-18 cannot be
used that way today by regulation so
that's our first business we're looking
at there's some others along the way as
our power levels would rise and
probably one of the more interesting
ones even before you get to break-even
with these devices is having enough
proton fluence that you can begin to
transmute systematically transmute
radioactive waste it's going to be an
interesting engineering designed to how
you get the flow of the waste past your
your proton fluence but I'm satisfied
that engineers are clever enough to
figure that out and we haven't started
to work on that yet we've been primarily
focused on the positron emitting an
isotope reduction
well I'm reluctant to give anyone advice
however it was the advice I gave this
administration in mid 2001 and that is
that and one of them they're doing now
because they have to do it and that is a
Delta flight readiness review of the
Space Shuttle unfortunately it was not
done earlier and who knows where they
would picked up that flaw or not but it
certainly was clear that they're not
things that happened to impact shuttle
operations that it was time to take a
deep breath and and look at it this was
two years ago the the main thing that I
think Sean O'Keefe has concentrated on
what everybody thought was job one for
NASA and that is to fix the financial
management system of the agency but
there were there was job two and three
as well that should have been taken on
at the same time and I just don't know
whether that has been and one was
program management NASA had forgotten
how to conduct program management they
were paying bills to major contractors
without looking at what milestones and
others if they didn't have the
milestones for one thing take the X 33
for example and they just they'd
forgotten what program management meant
and also in a more in the the and the
the NASA had forgotten what risk
management meant and that both from the
technical and the financial side of
things how do you manage your risk and
they just had weren't doing that now
whether that is being done now in the
agency I just don't know but if I were
to advise the administrator at this
point I say you've got to focus for the
long term on the financial the program
and the risk management systems and get
them up to speed so you can indeed
manage these large programs and manage
them with minimum risk I you know I
would have had an entirely different
space program had I been asked in 1972
or 73 but that's water under the bridge
now and you you have to use what you
have as long as you get is
reasonable to use it and look onto the
future and see what what can be done i I
don't know that NASA can they can get
that the sustained support as it is as
it exists today for a return to deep
space I suspect they'll be able to
sustain support for continued operations
in low-earth orbit and space station
operations but I just I don't know how
right now you put these things together
now may be a significant initiative by
the Chinese will stimulate other
thoughts in the Congress and then the
administration will just have to wait
and see yes sir
pilots
well let me take that from two
perspectives if if you were going to fly
an Apollo 18 I think that with a
three-person crew and maybe a few more
days I think the the mix of a of a pilot
and a trained field geologist is a good
mix and because particularly if the
pilot is as willing as most of the crew
the commanders of the last few Apollo
missions were - to learn a lot about
what observational field geology is all
about you can't substitute a decade or
two of experience in a short period of
time but you certainly with test pilots
you're dealing with good observers
anyway people who are well educated and
bright to begin with and so we I think
all the teams were pretty good teams the
only speak for the two I worked with
dick Gordon and Gene Cernan and I think
we did about as much as you could expect
to do under the circumstances the now if
you begin to look at much longer
duration stays for scientific purposes
then you clearly will have pilots you'll
want pilots to get you get other
specialists to there and back but you'll
probably get more into the kind of
operation of a space shuttle program
where you have a bit of a dichotomy
between the pilots and the
other professionals that will be doing
specialized tasks and that same probably
applies to if you do it with a private
sector effort is that you the private
sector corporation would probably be
hiring pilots as their routine operators
of spacecraft back and forth to the moon
and then have maybe even more diverse
specialties than even NASA would
consider - ranging from people who can
operate highly robotic but still not
fully robotic mining systems processing
systems as well as
geologists can call them economic
jealousy will who are doing the
precursor planning mind planning and
that kind of thing it becomes a much
more sophisticated operation with a wide
variety of skills required engineering
design for example for for any I think
corporate effort on the moon is going to
include all not only a focus on robotic
operation of equipment but also on
embedded diagnostics just-in-time
maintenance a whole bunch of things like
that that have to be done so you don't
stop operating because you're going to
have contracts to fulfill back here on
earth it creates a quite a different
perspective I think on how you engineer
things when you have to think in terms
that everything I do wrong hasn't cost
me money and cut and cut the investor
return it's it's an interesting new way
to look I never looked at things like
that before until about 10 years ago and
I started to think along these lines
that it might be more predictable than
working with the government yes sir that
is known I know the last eruption namely
sunset crater was in 1066 I think they
heard about the Norman invasion and
decided
to erupt the but that that has been an
act he feel far for millions of years
earlier than that and I I just don't
know the exact numbers you know clearly
it was active before the last major
glaciation because there's a great
glacial Cirque in the top of Mount
Humphreys if you've ever been up there
it's really quite a spectacular place to
hike and climb is in that glacier that
fed out actually fed out to the north
east I believe from the top of the
mountain yes sir standing on the moon
was my most memorable impression was
probably standing on the moon you know
certainly not something I anticipated
doing before before November of 1964
when I saw the announcement on a
bulletin board and Flagstaff that NASA
wanted scientists astronauts to apply
I'm not sure they wanted it but at least
the National Academy said they wanted it
and and it all worked out the I did I
just that was not something that I had
planned to do and and I've often advised
young people is that that's one reason
why you've got to try to get as broad
and as detailed simultaneously education
you possibly can to be ready for the
next opportunity that you don't know
about and and fundamental to all of that
is having a background in mathematics
because it's the language of opportunity
in any kind of technical or scientific
field and it should be thought of as a
language if if we don't see and I don't
I doubt if there's anybody in this
audience that doesn't agree with this
but I think that that one of the biggest
thing we do to hurt young people today
is keep them from learning mathematics
at any time when they're young as a
language they don't like to use it they
can often do other things but if you
don't have it you've eliminated a whole
spectrum of professional opportunities
in the future that you just never be
able to grasp the but meanwhile back on
the moon I suspect that the full
realization
being there did not really click on
totally until about 30 minutes after I
was outside the spacecraft and had a
chance to move away from the lunar
module challenger and to take the first
set of panoramic pictures that we wanted
before we've totally trashed the place
and and and that was the first time I
was able to see the lunar module in the
context of this immense mountain valley
we were in a valley deeper than the
Grand Canyon the mountains on either
side were six seven thousand feet high
black sky brilliant blue earth and of
course a brilliant Sun as bright as any
Sun that you can imagine and to finally
have a chance to see all of that while I
was taking this panoramic picture was
really probably when I first the impact
of being there hit me it wasn't it
didn't stop me or anything like that but
you start to absorb those kind of things
at that point prior to that I was
dealing with a spacecraft that I was
very familiar with it I'd worked simmer
and around and the test bays that at the
Kennedy Space Center I had worked with
many lunar modules and particularly this
one in the past so it was not and your
field of view is always restricted a
little bit in those helmets so I was
looking at an old friend that somebody
and I was working around it and I hadn't
really seen what I was going to see
until I moved away from that spacecraft
and that was really it was quite an
event
yes
no I you know apologist sort of
triggered revolution in data handling
data processing information and the like
the the the draper primary guidance
navigation system the pings that we use
to go to the moon was barely a
calculator and most of the computing was
being done by several floors of IBM what
were they thirty-three hundreds at that
time or who knows but a huge IBM
computers down here on earth and the the
results of that computation then fed
into our computer which was just capable
of using it for extraordinarily precise
landings so it was it was certainly
adequate to the job we landed within a
few tens of meters of where we planned
to land on every mission except Apollo
11 and and would have landed evenly had
we just let the computer take us exactly
where he wanted to go rather than taking
over a manual control we would have
landed essentially right where we
planned the spot but usually there was a
boulder or crater at that point and you
wanted to move away from it that it
seemed like a rational thing to do at
the time the just an example of the of
what we were doing with some of most of
you some of you may know that we were
delayed 2 hours and 40 minutes in our
launch because of the of a computer
glitch the is one of those garbage in
garbage out things where for some reason
in the launch control computer way back
and then lost in the dark ages the
computer had been told in the final
countdown checks that occurred at 30
seconds to look and see if a tank had
been told to be pressurized rather than
whether it was pressurized and when it
went through that at an earlier point
through that control it the tank the one
of the oxygen tanks in the I think the s
1c stage had been told will be
pressurized it didn't react to that come
from the computer and a launch
controller saw that that happened and
just punched it and manually pressurized
the tank so the tank was perfectly
alright it was pressurized ready to go
but the computer didn't know it and so
at 30 seconds it finally said I'm not
gonna let you go well it's just what you
wanted it to do if it wasn't sure but
you can see that it was looking at the
wrong parameter why it wasn't told to
look at a pressure transducer in the
tank I don't know but that held things
up for two hours and 40 minutes most of
which was time it took to convince NASA
management that the people knew what was
wrong it didn't take very long to figure
out what was wrong it turns out and and
but to solve it what they did was just
went into the computer and hardwired
around that particular Junction I I
don't know exactly what I'm doing but
they actually hardwired in that computer
all right these are huge banks of
computers and they found the place and
hardware so that as far as a computer
cern everything was hunky-dory and the
next time we went through 30 seconds off
we went
yes sir
I I think that it's just about
everything that I mentioned in my early
charts except the having met the Cold
War challenge would have to be
considered surprise because if you go
back and look at what was being thought
of in 61 62 63 we weren't thinking that
we would ever get those kinds of things
out of this mission there were a few
people like Jean shoemaker
Harold Urey who and a few others who on
the science side felt that this would
just be an amazing bonanza but the vast
community really wasn't paying attention
to to this the the idea that we would
find resources on the moon that could
support space civilizations nobody
talked about that that I can remember at
the time in fact the the importance of
helium-3 wasn't recognized to to future
energy supplies wasn't recognized until
1985 when when a some engineering
physicist stumbled across it in our
literature which had been there since
1970 the solar the people interested in
solar wind physics had had measured it
because that's where it came from and
they knew about was there and they they
went about their their papers wrote
papers on it and everything like this
but their interest was in solar wind
physics and not in weather it was a
resource and hunt and then once you
start to look at that you realized well
there's hydrogen there too and that from
hydrogen you can make water and and you
have the oxygen of course in the rocks
so that was totally unintuitive nobody
people just had not thought about that
and it and and and from the evolutionary
status of the species I never heard
anybody talk about that until well after
Apollo was was passed so clearly the
objective was made that's what everybody
signed up for as to land on the moon and
fortunately people like George Lowe some
of you knew George and Bob Gilruth Sam
Phillips and and Verner von braun they
all sort of had this vision that we were
going to do a lot more with apollo than
anybody thought we were going to do and
frankly I think that began to be obvious
when you realize that the lunar module
and the Saturn 5 and the command module
were all way over designed in the final
analysis to just land on the moon and
come home the the lunar module actually
right from the very beginning the first
design reference mission that Grumman
did had a four-day stay and on Brown you
know he'd give you a little bit more for
every mission and but at the beginning
nobody thought we would put 44 metric
tons on a trajectory to the moon with a
Saturn 5 he may have but he didn't tell
anybody about it and we had to squeeze
every metric ton out of him for Apollo 8
Politan he'd give you a little more for
Apollo 10 a little more for Apollo 11
yeah you know I had some secret little
supply of thrust that he had over here
and he kept giving it give me a little
bit more but for Apollo 17 it was the
heaviest payload and it was a 44 metric
tons to the moon and that's a heck of a
heck of a launch and we had that for a
while we had that kind of capability one
thing just to think about and then I'll
stop because I know Wes is trying to
give me the hook here but for a very
brief period of time between nineteen
literally between 1968 1972 we had the
capability to do something about an
asteroid or comet that might be on a
trajectory to impact the earth you don't
have that capability now technologically
you could recreate it but you don't have
it so we're in a very unique position
right now in terms of human civilization
there's still a major debate and major
discussion and I don't know what my
opinion is on whether you know how much
investment you make an extraordinarily
low risk but extraordinarily high
consequence events in predicting and in
in preventing such events but at least
we are at a point right now where we can
have that discussion and it's a
realistic discussion and that's one of
the side benefits of some initiative
that gets us back to the moon is that
you also create this capability again
and create it indefinitely because
you're always going to need heavy lift
launch to work in deep space ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much it's been
a great three with you
Jack we sincerely thank you as a
geologist a pilot an astronaut
administrator a business person a writer
and a Senate senator you have certainly
provided us with a very stimulating
account of what happened
on our way to the moon and what our
future may may be like so thank you so
very very much jack I will also like to
take this opportunity to say thanks to
two people who really guide us to this
particular event
professor Merman and Peggy Newton thank
you both very very much
and to our audience again thank you for
coming and for your stimulating
questions this concludes the 31st
Lester gardener lecture thanks again
[Applause]
you